thank you
thank you it took me a while to get
there uh
i reviewed his book a few years back
without having read any philosophy and
uh yeah i don't i don't let's not talk
about that
i actually wanted to make this video
because i think you will really like
nietzsche as well he's a german
philosopher born in 1844 and before we
dig too much into this i just want to
preface by saying that you know i'm not
an expert i'm just making this video to
hopefully inspire you guys to dig into
his readings as well because there's so
many misconceptions about nietzsche that
sort of makes you wonder if anyone's
ever actually read him as someone who
did read him and didn't understand
anything
but for me it was really fun to discover
just how wrong i was with all the
assumptions that i had about him the
only thing that actually turned out to
be right is that he has the most
beautiful mustache that probably the
world will ever see most of you are
likely to have heard of nietzsche
already i think he's just so popular
he's referencing movies you probably
heard of one of his quotes most famously
god is dead and we have killed him and i
think you hear these things and you make
assumptions about him crazy mustache
weird name philosopher guy it led me to
believe that nietzsche was a nihilist
especially since it seemed like
teenagers appropriate him as a symbol
for
thinking that life is pointless and i
like nietzsche i'm a nihilist kind of
kind of view maybe that's just me but i
remember seeing in the movie uh it
turned uh what was it called sunshine
something but what nietzsche actually
stood for was something really beautiful
and that i think a lot of these
teenagers could benefit from which is
his life affirming philosophy that's
right nietzsche wasn't a nihilist you
could argue that he was because some
some views that he has
could fit that category but in general
he actively fought against nihilism that
life is pointless nietzsche more than
anything wanted you to say yes to life
and i don't know how things get so
twisted
and guys i don't i don't mean to call
you out okay but i do stream a lot and a
lot of times when i get questions or you
know people tell me about their own
lives a common thing seems to be that
there's a lack of meaning or a lack of
purpose or whatever direction you're
going in life it doesn't feel right and
and i feel for you i really do
this sort of lack of meaning and lack of
purpose comes to the conclusion that you
know like most school of thought that
life is suffering and nietzsche of
course also recognized that life has
suffering but he brilliantly turns the
suffering
on its head nietzsche actually
criticized people that wanted to remove
suffering because according to him
suffering is what gives value or meaning
to your life without pain life would
just be meaningless and absurd and he
believed that the best moments in life
comes from suffering we can all relate
to the feeling of joy
after undergoing a very difficult task
you know it's the basic plot resolve out
of any movie as well really pain is
unavoidable in our lives so why not give
it a purpose there's obviously a limit
to how much suffering you can endure and
that person by nietzsche's logic the
person who can endure the greatest
amount of suffering is
the greatest person according to
nietzsche you know he is a bit harsh
here but i think that's what makes him
interesting it reminded me of my
favorite part of one of my favorite
novels which is the count of monte
cristo and it's when the count says
there is neither happiness nor misery in
the world there is only the comparison
of one state with another nothing more
he who has felt the deepest grief is
best able to experience supreme
happiness and this is coming from the
count who had undergone in the story of
this immense journey of suffering
nietzsche has written a vast library of
work and there's a ton of very
interesting concepts that maybe you've
heard about before like the ubermensch
the will to power
slave master and slave morality and but
i wanted to keep this simple and focus
on the life-affirming philosophy and my
favorite passage from nietzsche is
the eternal recurrence which is this
idea that life is a cyclic thing that
has been reoccurring and will continue
to reoccur for infinity this idea of a
cyclic time isn't unique to nietzsche
per se
even the greeks had a had an idea of it
and nietzsche gives this poor attempt to
try and explain how it's possible with
conservation of energy but it is
interesting how it is you know it's not
theoretically impossible we know that
with parallel universes now but it's
also kind of besides the point it's more
of an a test to see if you're affirming
life and it goes like this if some day
or night a demon were to steal after you
into your loneliest loneliness and say
to you this life as you now live it and
have lived it you will have to live once
more and innumerable times more and
there will be nothing new in it but
every pain and every joy and every
thought and sigh and everything
unutterably small or great in your life
will have to return to you all in the
same succession and sequence would you
not throw yourself down and gnash your
teeth and curse the demon who spoke thus
or have you once experienced a
tremendous moment when you would have
answered him you are god and never have
i heard anything more divine i have
and i'm very thankful for that it's uh
what's what during my wedding when i was
dancing with marzia
i felt as being surrounded by my family
i had this moment of feeling like you
know what whatever my life turns to at
least i had this moment but that's not
the point of the
necessarily of the statement it's to
give importance to this life and it's a
good thing to ask yourself that and the
way you live
life right now and the path you're in
would you want to take that path 100
times more a lot of times we go down
roads that i think a lot of us have this
notion that once i do this then i will
be happy or once i'm i get to this point
then you know i will be be satisfied
it's sort of a wake-up call for
decisions that you make in life and
nietzsche wants you to recognize life
and all its suffering and at the end of
it say yes that was life one more time
please once more and that's life
reformation and and that's to me it's
the the beauty of neat [ __ ] i hope you
enjoyed this video if you did subscribe
like all that stuff always appreciate
all the support and i'll see you guys
tomorrow bye bye
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes are emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this